[Musik]
fragt man die paradis einblicke ins
paradies eindrücklicher dokumentarfilm
von stefan duell aber sind das wirklich
blick dieses paradies ich denn schon mal
über gestorben und dessen jens okay ich
dass sie mit dem jesus von nazareth er
sich am kreuz gestorben verstanden und
deine sinne jüngerinnen und jünger
erschiene so stolz doch in der bibel
oder helfe die sogenannte nahtoderlebnis
vita wenn es um den sitzgurt oder
vorstellig vor der reinkarnation überall
die frage diskutiert mit mini geist der
marke meyer
sie ist meditations- lehrerin mit deren
eigenen meditations- schulen eine
interreligiöse in köniz die bern
sie ist bis 2012 auch präsidentin sie
vor die schweizerische vereinigung für
psychologie sie seit mit dem tod singen
bezüge unter der menschen nicht beendet
das simon keller erich römisch
katholische theologieprofessor für
spiritual care also das wäre die
spirituelle begleitung verstärkende und
vor anker menschen der lehrstuhl hätte
er an der universität zürich
und er spricht auch als spitals
entsorger tätig zum anfang persönliche
frage was erwartet sie noch 1 bot
spannende abenteuer dass es wieder gott
und möglichkeit sache war jetzt
unbefriedigend im eigenen lager sind in
irgendeiner form könne liter zwei jahre
hit zu landen letztlich abenteuerlich
dass die hoffnung und aber bewies er sei
danach ihre verbindung folien sitz und
der welt ein greller wie ist das für sie
ich habe mir am start gesagt vor dem
kantonsarchäologe wo seit wenn er sich
das paradies vorstellten ist sowohl ein
präsenz ganz gut so
ganz wie sich sie auch ganz sie
bezüglich sie also stelle ich mir das
vor oder sogar nicht sehr konkret wie
kann man der übergang konkrete vorstelle
so was übergang ist liegt das paradies
selbe stelle mir eigentlich nicht vor so
es ist so iris erlebnisqualität wo ich
damit verbindet aber es ist ja beide
ganz klar für märz noch beim laufen
weiter die kirchen würden oft nicht
immer die spiele danach wissen was in
china tours herztropfen wo sie der wind
alle haben zugeguckt das ist sie erst
der gang zurück gefunden
dorothee tabu thema redet eigentlich
nicht über das was man selber glaubt mir
frank teil nicht so sagte das ist tabu
ist galt redet nicht über geld bekommen
und so andere sieht ich bin mir ganz
seltsame aussage vater nachgeschmack
bleibe aber bisher sehr halbherzig und
ihrer lang suchte nach worten sie können
formulieren dass gott ihr nicht darum
den weg die syrische toll was sie
zeigten dass sich seite und so weiter
und medien hannover kurz vorm eine
theologie professoren ich sage hoch in
einig von margit schmid bekannte
evangelischer dialog und die wird ein
regal voller will das gefühl war sagte
diesem buch über mystic vor der
weltreligionen schrieb das ist ein
großes tableau von ruß tatsächlich mit
einem film dass ich mir den sinn kommen
am schluss ja wenn sie schon so klasse
entscheiden die antwort was macht wo
sind die reformierte us-import bestand
wo sehen sie jedoch mystic
und muss sagen sie sind eigelege jene
mutter nach 8
das gesetz schreibe seit der schmied
protestantismus schämt sich religion zu
sein
der protestant glaubt wenn er glaubt wie
wenn er nicht glauben möchte er betet
wenn er betet wie wenn er nicht beten
würde und so weiter
und durch meine apps rote linsen co wir
sind kürzlich im new york sehr
befreundet die tage im job suche und hat
unserer hund mitgenommen hat erkannt was
da und überhaupt den kirchen dorf und
merck geschworen dass ich aber ganz ganz
wichtig gottes sie im schnitt störe und
gar nicht und bremen erhofft hat oder
gottes stehen schmiss an einer stelle
und was ist stellt wurde ganz meint ruf
standen ist uns unser vater wartet und
darum dass sich aus
und was ist los ist war ich moniert
macht hat das aufstellen und halb acht
siege reden
mit welchen technologien setzt das auf
die ansage bus jeden sie zurück macht
wird familie ist er über 80 ist
energetisch ist vom egal unterschied
zwischen der polizei es ist ein
schwarzes loch sich als verblieb und den
nur sagen ich singe designer können sich
auch lebendig was ich empfinde jetzt
bedruckt wie heute der film ist oder was
sie was die menschen ernste themen und
genau also die gesicht strahlt sogar
wieder wachsen
schlusspunkt armen dass es kommt sogar
die hand haltend verzählt also dass der
film bis nichts originelles auch kreativ
sky hält man gewisse vorstellungen sind
sehr konventionell sie aber irgendwie
sind es dann gleich mit originellen art
und dies ist für zählt worden ist
meister berührt hat mir schon so
hauptgeschichte also die bergwanderin
mit dem vater und der sei der vater
dieter dem ort
zwar stehe und wandern oder irgendwen
ist dass das war sie also es ist eine
strategie zu werden
oder hätte gewundert und so die
emotionale bewältigung von ihm als eher
niedrig ist wie beides für mich oder
also das berührende die aussage aber
aber mäßig seid ja was ich so etwas
erwartet oder die hoffentlich noch 1 2
aus
ab morgen ja prima
ja es ist doch nachvollziehbar
ben kweller es blieb das hübsche namen
fertig ja wenn man die perspektive zu
absolut irrt würde das haus hoch sei wie
die erste frau das sei der plötzliche
perspektive des menschlichen lebens gibt
die eine perspektive und das tatsächlich
so dass das ist das menschliche
bewusstsein menschliche leben sich
wandelt und jetzt hier physikalische
körperlichkeit also absolut wird setze
ich habe einen frontalen große
weltreligion sind das an sich die frage
stellen so dass das die einzige
perspektive aufs leben also die gibt's
aber der gedanke und auf vielfältige
vollständige bis heute wieder genau habe
und das ist für sie mehr als einfach als
hochrechnung von einem meter hängt ja
mein natürlich können sie ticks leben
nicht anders vorstellen als sie deiner
bilder wo ist so verwirklicht stöhnt und
wilde entnehmen diese lebenswelt können
wir gar nicht anders
und das sind immer bilder dass ich denke
schon wichtig dass wenn wir über das
thema reden uns bewusst sind dass man
halt in re sprach welt entworfen wie
seitens welt reicht ist so also dass das
bild der kritische moment braucht denn
das projekt ist gott findet automobil
die bilder sind passend weil die stifter
nick ja aber es klingt so sieht das
einfach fertig ist auf jeden fall hat
das sie so wie damals ist es bitter für
bandic fest mit einer box ballbesitz
sind hier zu deiner überzeugung der
bestellung viele toten tote sind den
lebenden böse
das ist behauptet und das wird er sagen
verbindung und minister begründete die
familie spielen für philips stehen und
dass ich eins von ihnen nach wenn es
gebe jetzt wo die hufen erfahrung
sammelt der letzten 15
und da sehen wir das aber wäre uns
persönlich zu der überzeugung dass
israel ihm aber sie persönlich ja aber
sie könne sie machen ja frage wenn sie
das mache phänomenologische schaaf will
mitglied wo die familie geschäft
überhaupt nicht kenne mit stellvertreter
und sie stelle fest was durch passiert
und und können es nachricht abchecken
mit denen er liegt um die es geht sind
die familien
es ist nicht zu ende aber die situation
ist sehr umstritten oder vor den vorgang
user dort zeigen sie können es fragt
sich einfach wahnsinn ruft sondern auch
vögel oder nicht wenn sie sich auf die
erfahrungen möchte sie nun sagen mit dem
tod ist fertigen sie hände sauber also
berichtet über das ergebnis wo sie
selber kann ist dass er notfalls sie im
weiteren sinn ja also es ist nicht so
sexy war auch dass sie hart stillstand
kann das sind kriterien man arbeitet ja
absolut bewusst dienst zu erstand unter
kontakt und hielt dann was man keine
gewalt an frauen oder wie valery
situation aber in einer extremsituation
in hamm anschläge und den händler bis
sehe oder gespürt oder größte
kommuniziert also das was liegt
mystisches nennen oder vision oder wie
sie dem land sage was geht's lang ist
das her
werden sie viel über das notwendig da
kam das sei der sinn oder
es hat mir aber vollständig verändert
die bedenkenträger sowie sagen hat dann
vertretbar wenn die religiöse mensch
wacht und haben rudolf steiner gemacht
blonski bibel klasse müsste bibel jakob
böhme was was immer sie wenn sie sind
die ökonomen von us-diplomaten jetzt sie
und einige interessante werke aus als
alles kann jetzt nicht persönliches
erlebnis kann ihren erlebnis haben mobil
das jetzt für mich persönlich glauberg
wieder direkte rolle spielt aber das
passt idee selber hang dass nach dem tod
von tierischen und rabbiner co
trotz der großen liebe christa worte an
die denn so ein zwei wochen nach dem tod
so sind stimmt so innerlich gehört also
in dem sinn die verbindung mit
verstorbene hat schwebt also die
erfahrung machte erwischen oder rentner
zu mir das ist das stichwort gesehen wo
jetzt inhaltlich gefüllt seminare sind
die präsenz hat spielberg sie dass apple
mit dem moment hatte bisher trist jetzt
kann ich aber nicht unbedingt an als sie
dass sie dem thema den mittelgang bin
maschinerie dass sie viele kranke und
sterbebett 17 oder als seelsorger genau
da ist mir natürlich zum teil
nachrichten biete im sterbeprozess von
beamer in der regel halt die perspektive
gesehen wo sie benannten also das label
prozent geholt und ganz 10 kommt also
der körper wo stirbt genau an scooter
körper spürbar ist also die radikalität
vor dem übergang oder foto problemen
abschluss aber ich würde die organe
welle bagatellisieren also das ist aber
meine christliche ethik soli zu und den
moment das wissen darf der sohn mit der
sterbe das ist wie mit der metro seien
sie zu wenig über das hinwegtröstet
werde so schnell dass das ein schwerer
abschied casini und aber irgendwie mit
schmerz und und und schwierigen
erfahrungen von unternehmen oder
seelsorger kann ihn natürlich frauen mit
der es nicht wenn ich es genau fertig
und was meine lampe muss meine
überzeugung gäbe also was ich also der
christliche bezüge für die dass es so
wenig über lagerung sowie zwei
lebenszyklen wenn man sieht also dass
ein lebenszyklus sich anschließt also
der metalli lebenszyklus mit dem tod
fertig ist aber das ist nur ein anderer
lebenszyklus geht wo aber nicht später
stunde anfangs ein eigener shop in
früheren das neue leben ist das wort
eigentlich gar nicht so wie in zu sehen
wir hätten die eine wirklichkeit die
vielschichtige ist und die wirklichkeit
zu deiner verstorben hierdurch trinkt
eigentlich die möglichkeit dass wer das
jenseitige leber weg sei die noch nicht
so konkret die bilder dazu die abstrakte
begriff wo ich damit brauchen wir
intensive bezüglich also dass so die
also alles was ist kostbar ist und was
mir das wertvoll und sinnhafte dem leben
erleben
libby bezüglich es sinnvoll dass das in
der potenzierten atem dienst wieder gut
aber wir genau daran milito stehen aber
es dennoch wünscht ein krone
das kann man natürlich immer alle
religiöse überzeugung hier der kritische
wand stellen und wichtigste pixel
wunschdenken
also ich wünsche mir was hatte sie den
grundstein
gleichzeitig spürt oder sie wollen dafür
kriegen dialog mit dem theologen aber
gern mit der reformierte theologie
wieder viel zug kann
durch das thema ich möchte aber dass
erst über die sogenannte nahtoderlebnis
noch luft kurz kommt und mit probieren
hat ja dass sie es schaffen
das ist ein punkt war immer wieder
genannt wird wenn jürgen büser mal und
einen dokumentarfilm besonders
nahtoderlebnis claire stiefel war sechs
jahre alt als sie fast ums leben kann
es passierte im sommer sie war allein am
greifen sie obwohl sie nicht schwimmen
konnte geht andere jugendliche seewolf
matratze hand und das habe ich einfach
traumhaft spannend und ich hätte so gern
benutzten so lampert bis hin zu schnell
vergangen bin uns musiker hand und dann
bin ich halt auf der luftmatratze musik
sport und hornet ist dass man sich die
offene kasse ihre und so ist es halt
passiert dass sie dann möglich aber gut
spielen und sie an immer gewünscht haben
versucht habe ich darauf ist eben aber
dass chancenlos sieht und irgendwann ist
kraftlos gegangen und bin einfach
untergegangen
dann ist plötzlich einfach angst wächst
[Musik]
es ist möglich für sich einfach
umfassend und und ergreifend und
erschütternd und erfüllend und ich weiß
es nicht
und ja ich weiß nich bisher trug sie wie
sehr traurig sie dass das oft das schöne
gefühl ein mann rettet das mädchen was
ihr bleibt ist eine tiefe sehnsucht an
diesen ort zurück
ja und sie ist aber nicht aus dem
jenseits
wie ordnen sie sollen erfahren hier
schien es wichtig einmal zu betonen dass
die erfahrung
dies wurde todesgrenze stattfinden sogar
um erlebe für deine person selber also
die aussage dass das eben dass wir die
person trug sie weg und dann so eine
radkarte sind empirischen die devise es
gibt auch not oder farbige menschen von
kerngesund sind also keine spur von eine
physische todes teil hängt also
bergsteiger wo aber stürzt sind und
unheil und und die den zehn sekunden wo
sie der fallenden tools noto der fall
collini tode fertig machen also wir
sehen ja keine gesund also der medizin
nicht gar nicht gar nicht im lauf der
eigentlich gar nicht dass sie sich not
oder für alle tische schockartige
konfrontation mit todes nicht so wie es
heißt und das ist mit intensiven ganz
intensive erfahrungen verbunden wo man
ähnlich wie sauber sterben findet ist
ein anderer typ ist also wichtig ist
dass man zur kenntnis nimmt dass
vielfalt von auto.de fahriger geht also
das system sind über die sg typus von
auto oder fahrrad
[Musik]
juli hier ist allerdings das ist also
das unheil geht das bei mir auch
dennoch sind viele berliner den film
aber auf kurze anders sehen und sie will
es geht doch klassische note oder farbig
und gäbe findet statt bei herzstillstand
also deren funktion ausgesetzt eigene
geschäft betont da man so nicht
unbedingt keine kehren funktionen die
man ja also erstens weiß auch dass also
der nicht einig sind genau die seelen
ich kennen uns zweiten ist dass man wenn
er über notruf alle gezählt weil im
augenblick eher der fall so der
standpunkt vertreten dass die pin von
goya genau das ist das niveau sei das
geht durchaus bewusst sie muss in einer
vorstufe vorher genau wo siehst du wo
einfach jede maria riesch 80 prozent
20 prozent sind im lehnitzsee
das muss man zur kenntnis nahm also man
kann nicht einfach sagen jaja es neues
lied wonderful druck sie will dort vor
dort wo zeit naturwissenschafts hitze
und rammstein schnell dass sie an die
universität professor peter-andré
sensibilität als berücksichtigen und sie
es geht wenn sie aus wie oft spitze
triebe kam es in konflikt mit raschen
der naturwissenschaft
das ist sexy das ist unumgänglich und
doppelt auf erzählt die geschichte von
sokrates vor dem krieg muttertag
komischerweise ist ein wichtiger
weil er vor bremen und dem netz stellen
meint nach dem zahltag droht kommt laut
prenzler und zeigt ihr habt ruft trag zu
zählen sei aber gut möglich dass gerade
jene bürger wurde also wenn das thema
diego mit dem pim van lommel gattung
schwierig alter wähler für mit zu
naturwissenschaftlichen stelle das
modell wo er es als mediziner grüner
etwa starker liebsten oder lieb gemeint
bau die tourismusvertreter eigentlich
noch einmal aufnimmt und spekulative
führt dass man muss ihm zugutehalten
dass er wirklich sehr seriöse
kardiologische notfall schick macht also
hier die empirische forschung und
gemacht hat wirklich sehr sehr seriös er
fand den allerdings spekuliert anderes
als buch schrieb dass er entwickelt den
ganzen respekt muss - perspektive
spekulative theorie über das bewusst sie
wo empirisch eigentlich nicht abstützt
sehen das wohl nicht mit der vorschrift
zur hand wenn er selber gemacht hätte
also die dss katie service wenn es ein
förmliches bewusst sie es ist deshalb
genauso punkte hat hier die note oder
farbiger die sprechen kann für das also
das ist sozusagen den sie nie theorie
wohne er auf das aufbaut und mini
perspektive auf das unten hin zur
gegangen haben den vorgang ist dass es
schwierig ist bitterer not diskussion
dass man immer so vor schluss so
spekulativ ist und das wetter bis
erkläre damit unterbietet man doch die
phänomen in sich massenhaft die
vieldeutige phänomen worden phänomen vor
in einer großer vielfalt auftauchen das
geht aber nicht nur mal die
himmelsmechanik es geht auch einfacher
durch mögliche formen von auto oder
fahrrad ich bin jetzt 33 wieso keine
generellen sitzen zwei behält also die
vielfalt einvernommen unterscheidet wir
verschiedene formen von bewusst sie den
muskeln fossile forschung oder und seit
es gibt durchaus bewusst sei unabhängig
von der kernfunktion
funktioniere das wird sie bestritten
ein wenig glaube alles noch im
physischen tod peter geht in eine andere
wirklichkeit so würde nicht
grundsätzlich bestritten dass es form
vor bewusst sie und leben geht wo jetzt
nicht mit mit physischer hirn
jetzt erhält nur über die zeiger das
lohnt sich jetzt in einer farbigen
ablehnen weil das ein anderer event auch
dass sie natürlich neurobiologe und jene
berichte anhob accent schnitt aus dem
dokumentarfilm an der schwelle zum
jenseits christian hoppe neurologe und
theologe der wissenschaftler der
universitätsklinik bonn gehört zu den
schärfsten kritikern der nahtod
erlebnisse wir gehen davon aus dass alle
mentalen phänomene dazu gehörten auch
wahrnehmung alle geistig seelischen
phänomene mit ihren prozessen
einhergehen und die sich in prozesse
notwendig sind für das zustandekommen
dieser mentalen phänomene und wer heute
noch anderes behauptet müsste dann
eigentlich uns das zeigen die
transzendenz erfahrungen etwa die
produkte einer hirnschädigung was die
personen in diesem erlebnis her nicht
miterleben können ist die noch
verbliebene aktivität im gehirn
es gibt wie gesagt kein hinweis darauf
dass das ohne diese prozesse
stattgefunden hat wenn man das jetzt
annimmt dann muss man davon ausgehen
dass im tod diese prozesse nicht mehr
fallen sind weil das gehirn zerfällt in
tot
vermutlich sind dann auch diese
erlebnisse nicht mehr möglich wenn man
das zuspitzen würde man sagen für die
frage was wird nach dem tod erlebt sagen
die nahtoderlebnis insofern nichts als
das eben hier noch jede funktion
vorhanden ist gotteserfahrung
oder die laune eines angeschlagenen
gehirns für christian hoppe lassen sich
viele der erlebnisse recht nüchtern
erklären
vor allem im bereich des rechten
scheitellappen dort werden die signale
aus dem körper verbunden mit den
signalen vom sehen und vom
gleichgewichtssinn und wenn diese
verschaltung nicht mehr richtig klappt
dann gibt es so etwas wie ein isoliertes
sehen
das geht einher mit dem gefühl zu
schweben so ein bisschen zufließen wenn
man hat keinen körper mehr weil die
körpersignale mit diesen informationen
nicht mehr verbunden werden und das wäre
wahrscheinlich die physiologische
grundlage für das entstehen von außer
körperlichen erlebnissen
das grüne licht erlebnis selbst könnte
mit einem weiteren verlust an sauerstoff
im gehirn zu tun haben eine störung der
funktion des hinterhauses lappens führt
zu einem licht erleben ja von meyers
nord erlebnis salzergebnis von einer
hirnschädigung sieht es kommt mir vor
wie wird sage warum mozart geniale musik
macht der geniale musik gemacht wenn
stein beflügelt steinweg flügel um
mögliche geniale musik mozart ist ganz
banale umsetzung steinway-flügel bringe
das ganze zu gewinnen ja so gut ist ein
wäre dann aber dem ist nicht so
vermehrung sehr brennt die cdu wenig
musik ist ja das ist richtig das feuer
dem schwanz und element sie ist noch
kurz erklären in die schädlich sind
strom und vom danke danke so viel nicht
zur kenntnis
das argument dass sie singen um ein
beethoven habe muss ich nämlich 8
aber hätte crash die großartigste
kompositionen von beethoven sind alle
passiert wenn man schon danke sehr viele
leute bis gar nicht längst in ihm
und wenn es nicht auf die aktive also
doch geschafft sich nachhaltig und was
beließ das also ist letzte glaubens
folgt und material geist schaffe das ist
dialekt ist realismus von
karl marx motto mitkriegen und vom
angels oder geherrscht
es gibt wirklich phänomen wo die
menschen dann schildert dass sie sowohl
anderen sie habt spielt dann könnt
schildere wie interpretieren sie das
meine es gibt viel parapsychologische
phänomene womit erklärt könnt und die
herr gaux bedürfnis die ärzte erklären
findet wieder das ist das problem von
der note gut erforscht das ist oft
erklärt spur ist es so und ich finde die
zu einer sitzt rechtfertigt also da
spricht ein punkt um listen
unterscheiden dass sie ein auto der
fahrer die setzend kernaktivität voraus
also ich bin ich und was er nicht und
das wäre der punkt wo sie versprechend
ist das auto der fahrer die menschen
geht wo gar keine pathologischen
veränderungen im integrierten funktionen
hängt also stark an so oder so erklärt
schien im richtigen selbst unerklärlich
auch durch bau der querung erfahrung
erklären
das sind ideale methode farbigen mit out
of body verbunden
also hätte kunden mit unserer
reduktionistischen erklärungsansätze
jetzt sogar für aussteller vom urlaub
lang in lausanne wo seit deren biologie
tod erfahren sind illusionen erzeugt im
gehirn gefunden das mit ihren
stimulieren ja aber er ist ja auch
wieder einer auf die autofahrer anhielt
und wie man die autofahrer die samstag
von auto.de fällig das ist das phänomen
für sich das hat eigentlich mit den
autofahrern zu lassen und das menschheit
erfahrung machen dass dann weitere dass
sie uns ab vom körper sich befindet und
situation war später vom sorge machte
dort ein glück sagen dass dieses
phänomen ist staatsmännisch mit motto
der nord oder farbiger verbunden ist mit
dem sich vereine interessant der punkt
jetzt nicht direkt zu den orten oder
falsch ist sie sind es neues buch wofür
ihnen beim keller jetzt werk denn unser
hund sind ereignisse in todesnähe oder
und da sagt sie
das jüngere empirische studien deuten
jedoch darauf hin dass es in todesnähe
er der normal als der ausnahmefall
darstellt das visionäre bleibe also mit
not- oder erleben sondern vision
herzklappe was ist damit gemeint mit der
note gut erfahrung ist ja so dass die
todesmärsche episodisch bleibt also dass
menschen das ja erleben können sie sich
aus ton für zähler
es geht verwandt die phänomen wohl
sterben das dokument schreiben
sterbeprozess hemd und der sterbeprozess
dürfen nichts lenkt sie also das
coaching 50 tag vom verstärker sie sogar
noch länger als wo menschen in einem
zustand in einen schlafzustand oder
allem nachts vorstand visionäre afrika
hin zum beispiel dass ihnen verstorbener
mensch wo ihnen gestanden ist erschienen
in den alten traum oder ja es ist ein
alter traum kann man sagen es geht auf
müssten die übergänge zwischen
traumartigen und visionären erleben
unterschied ist dass visionärs erlebe
mit der qualität von der hyper realität
verbunden ist also die wo das
lebensgefühl der wirklichkeit wohl da
erleben ist wirklich das wisse auftrags
wirklichkeit und das hätte normaler
traum nicht so aus wie normale tragen
die verschwinden wenn dir erinnert sich
um oder muskel nach einem vater ziehen
vereins notorisch aber über das wird
wenig geld und das ist interessant dass
über ein auto der fahrer so viel geld
wird auch über wieder medial sehr viele
besucher erschienen die partie das
visionäre erleben sterben durch viel
weniger erforscht so und es gibt
allerdings hat bahr jünger die
vorschläge wo sehr spannend sind und das
ist die forscher der studie auf die
matten stellen ein sprecher von einer
us-amerikanischen ist interessanter bis
studie die mit spitznamen durchgeführt
worden wo spiels patienten patientinnen
jeden tag gefragt wurde sind auf die
erfahrung
sein wie sie ihrem leben sind genau und
und so langsam möglich gehalten hat
betrunken sind sie täglich auf die
erfahrungen befragt worden sind
passanten ergebnis wo die
forschungsgruppe nicht erwartet hätte
ich das auch eine 80-prozentige
erfahrung von südafrika dunkel bezieht
zu deinem china muss sich fragen wie
lange über das faszinierend noch etwas
zeit jetzt das über das jenseits und
muss weniger forsch was ist denn mit
coupons schweizer karriere dort
durchlief 25 oder sollen sie sich mit
der forschung an meine frage was ich
mitte schweizer los was ich schön ihre
dass elisabeth sowie der grundsteuer
franz und ich glaube das ist die
entscheidende zwischen uns 27
das nicht unbedingt meine sie stehen
damit das unit naturwissenschaft wie sie
heute ist in frage stellt sich genau das
passiere logi weiß warum hat mir ganz
fünfte entfernte galaxien welle zu
forschen aber was rund nach dem tod was
spricht dagegen dass wissenschaftlich
als co falls vorschickt mache falls
sammler oft wichtige fortschritt was
spricht dagegen spricht dagegen dass
sprich liter gebinde alle bereiche wo
der wirklichkeit sollen möglichst gut
erwischt werde und parapsychologie
wendet sich stimmt der phänomen zu ich
glaube nicht dass man von der
erforschung über die fragen gehen sieht
sehr viel und hinten kann also alles was
ist gut für sehen sind müsse nicht sein
trauma von goethe oder war ja nicht
einmal über sie einsitz was ich denken
aus deinen ort erlebnis oder revision
heraus
also sie bestätigen einfach da sich das
wetter gott das ist der seite wo wie
viel ich nicht und ich finde zum
beispiel drehen kommissionsvorschlag
viel interessanter zu deinem freund aber
nur eine frage habt oder ich habe bis
krone
ich finde hier forscher einzelne
betriebe um irgendwie jenseits
vorstellungen zum thema mode oder nicht
sondern das phänomen sind
spencer todes hilfe können heutige
erfahrungen machen wenn wir alle wollten
das nicht werden co und heutige fahrer
vermutlich fertig machen also potenziell
ist es wichtig das genauso der letzte
grenzbereich diesem leber seriös
erforscht also darum ist problematisch
wenn man wenn man ausklammern das ist
natürlich nicht einfach vorstellen habe
ich ein wichtiger lebensbereich darum
ist es gut aber ich will ja häufig
übersehen sie immerzu teile volk
versteht die schau in dem film von
stefan kuhl fragen und paradis also ps
vorzeitig sterben und verstanden und
erschien seine jüngerinnen und jünger so
stolzen wir bieten wie zum beispiel
geschäft foto maria von magdala wohin
begegnet allerdings nicht genau weiß
besitzt der gärtnerisch oder den gibt es
die weitere jünger auf immer als kind
und als signal müsse werde mit ihnen
läuft und dann mussten uns urteilen gott
und den ich ja wieder weg was hemmt die
echse so was sie erlebt wie tragisch
dann fort sind und in der erlanger über
lieblings tradition der einmal
verschriftlicht wurde sehen also für dtm
jetzt nicht wahnsinnig viel in der hand
dass man diesen theologische texte
machen theologische aussage als wir sind
vielschichtiger also ganz viel dazu
sagen so viel glück sitzt also was es so
zeigen über die ufer steht vor dem jesus
ab leiter lothar hay punkt also wenn man
das so sagen
und jeder oder rück binder heutige
lebenserfahrung ist so dass das phänomen
dass verstorbenen erschienene ganz
häufig ist also nicht nur sterben die
heutige erfahrungen von ihnen erstellten
erschienen sondern interessante wie es
auch die evo zug blieben also wir
berichten staatlicher höflichkeit gegner
erschien xr farbiger dieser studie haben
wir eigentlich nach dem gar nix flog das
mädchen will wissen was für erfahre
erfahrung sterben die machen aber sind
eine reihe von seelsorge co
also zwei seelsorger sind berichtet dass
ein patient was länger begleitet hätte
nach dem tod noch mal erschienen ist
also die erfahrung von air china an und
für sich
das neue testament aber ich stelle dass
ich sie als männer gehört meister blumen
aufgabe wo man verbindet mit dem
verstorbenen person gehört ja es ist
schon eine personale begegnet wenn die
person wohin wichtig sie ist ihnen
einmal erschienen einmal so sieht also
zulächelt in vechta jetzt wort
innenseiten und jesus hat ja eine viel
gesagt also noch da nach deiner uster
bricht ist relativ still hätte dir dir
die menschen berührt so gesegnet und das
sind eigentlich genau die motive
herrscht dort als league tor
verschlossen
na ja es sind der chinese an der
wirklichkeit
außerdem sehen sind selber visio
visionen wo viel gültig sind und
natürlich immer wieder unterschiedliche
typen kann aber durch jetzt die
wunscherfüllung hypothese natürlich auch
naheliegend aber für die wo das erleben
ist das ganze wichtige persönliche
erfahrung wie gesehen ziehen sie sind
wieder reformierte tradition groß würde
schwierig zu entscheiden
und das ist so schwierig dass nachher
die ganze theologie durchs entstanden
ist und mit der anime also für mich das
ist für mich erst einmal eine
phänomenale lehrer also dort wo wirklich
jesus im o-ton konnte triebel das ist
sicherlich nicht die filiale nach wie
vor auch genial
obwohl sie zum teil schwierig zum
verdauen sind wenn sie an wie banken
oder andere talente oder so aber habe
also die lehre risch der lehrerin ist
genial und ich verstehe und die br
überzeugt dass ohne dass sony stark
warnte geändert xe beginn der neuen
zeitrechnung und so das sollte nicht
einfach verschwindet das lasse auf ihren
erfolgen auf neudeutsch das richtige
form packungen verwehrte und das ganze
aber durch venedig sehen was gegnern ab
dann jeweils und ich glaube das was man
selber rufs macht jetzt können auf
wunsch das macht was möchte ich denn
und sie haben dann fragt man es erwartet
sie in ihren sitz dass ich mir wohl
stammte das war vision wo revolution
immer wieder gott man alle habe jetzt
immer einfach vor durch revolution dar
da wie ein nationaler munde ausgabe to
stand ich vor mehr entwickeln und so und
einzig mit der seelen soll das nicht
kalt
kentridge parkett ein schwarzes loch
sich ganz fertig aus wie wichtig es ist
eine politische und auch den idylle vor
dem film trifft hierbei wieder inklusive
funkel mobilen vogel kann sich was ist
ein trojaner steinforth erhöhen oder
aber sie speichert die angst davor
gesehen was ich denn hier sehen
das ist das wollen wir im tod zugelegt
egal ob sie männlich oder die
dass meine jagd bis vor acht uhr und das
kann jeder mensch ich fühle das bringt
den film audio besteht klassisch mayo am
ende vor den wert legen wir lieben sehr
wieder zweimal geführt oder die
lieblichen verstehe ich dass man das
kurze sicht meint die biblische
vorstellig schaltete das sich im tod der
physische lieb und unter irgendeinen im
atelier trennen sondern tatsächlich dass
der mensch solches stirbt und noch heute
ist ein ländlicher vorstellung dass den
transformationsprozess geht der der
mensch bewegt wird und verstaut und zwar
immer lieblich also es gibt eigentlich
richtig die idee von 3 und lieblich der
seelisch platonisch also das ist
sozusagen der biblische tradition
abgeleitet sondern es ist immer der form
von mathematischer liebe sich der
vorstellten geistiger mit geist neumann
mit geist das beseelt irgend beseelt und
dann aber bis lieblich dass das ist
jetzt nicht die seele oder eben als
sandler wissens bewusst sie so alles
bleibt vorne
das ist ihr wichtig punkt also wenn ein
mensch das lateinische persönlichkeit es
ist leider hätten form wirkt und die
form blieb der halter die goldene
verloren also für einmal nur zu ganz
kritisch aber es werde noch wichtiger
dass jegliche idee dass liebe zählt rund
sind versperrt die geschichte
geschrieben und man sich vorgestellt hat
man der schlaf ist denn was an die
vorderen sitze die moderne theologie sei
die achte ich all die neue sogenannte
ökologische entwurf fertig es gibt
begegnet ihm droht mit gurt und betrieb
in dallas statt
also für unterwegs sollte es wie
griechenland
das bietet auch wenn sie sollte
sterbebett zero leute das ist ihr
vorstellig so bellen tourismus also wohl
der lieb so über trend wird vor der
fotoserie show immer noch also sehr
stark tatsächlich ist dort für
vermittler der theologische reflexion
von 20 jahrhunderts auf halbem weg staub
lebe wird dieser ski zwar soziologe wo
das eine sehr populäre atmung wie ist
das wenn ein gutes in populäre art
vermittler könnt aber so es ist nicht
jeder breite akku es ist nicht
vermittelbar
sie können ganz viel trainieren und das
versuchen so weit wir das nicht schaffen
weil es sich ja absuche die theorie
sie spricht nicht mit erfahrung zu
sammeln mein wenn menschen glauben
glaube sie will das in der bis bene
räsoniert und jetzt sage ich mal was
soll das räsonieren absuchte idee ist
aus dass eine einheit ist das ist das
kloster zarathustra zieht an das
vorkrisenniveau anknüpfen
im lehrplan bitte christen vor allem
bitte protestant ist nur 100 prozentig
einer bleibe das ist absurd keine
entspricht die erfahrung machen und sein
fahrer vorne transformationsprozess
geredet worden
mal stattfindet war macht der
transformationsprozess gut dabei was hat
massig strom von menschen wahnsinnig der
menschen habe das maximum unter die
hochs ob man in der bibel statt 70 bis
80 70 bis 80 geruch können sie vorab
mache sie können zuhören sie können eine
ortung vergab ich dass ich einen
mitmenschen gab es ihr können und somit
und nachher ist das ende der
fahnenstange erreicht der evolution auf
durch waltraud zwar wieder wieder einen
meter zu erhöhen
und so zart usters sieht meiner dankt
wald gott drei dose jedoch im maximum
das sind vorstellungen die
naturwissenschaft schuldig wenn die
probleme und sie sind wieder zusammen
redet jetzt von berbens dem vertrag den
v6 mit 878 unsere serie im kühlschrank
sie und erachtete bist gott macht eine
zarte entweder seid ja über spürt den
himmel
du hast unzählige verdacht oder was ist
habe sich um christliche und verstehen
und sie darstellen also mindestens ist
nicht nur stillstand da ich verstanden
dass ich nichts verstehe natürlich dass
hintergrund der theologische
auseinandersetzung mir händ jetzt halt
sagen medien katholische tradition
bisher seine farben beschrieben und es
geht natürlich reformierte tradition
also muss man sehr 20 jahrhundert also
der theologische diskussion also die
sogenannte ganz tot these wo immer die
vorstellung schreitet also mit dem tod
ist tatsächlich alles also der mensch
als ganzes stirbt er wird den von gottes
ganzes auch wieder erweckt werde so die
katholische tradition ist er da für
andere china selbst versuchte der seele
gedankens transformieren idee richtig
ist sagt ein arzt dritten also für sie
gestalt gestalt für die menschen halten
blieb das eben so ist die personalie
kern also das sozial gut was er
geschafft hat ist nicht vor ort sondern
in einem transformationsprozess nimmt
und deckel genau das passiert was sie
jetzt so schildert erfahren auch wie
viel co2 also in dem sinne ist das
natürlich auch inhalt oder christlicher
theologie
diese pluralität dauer die vielfalt wird
halt leider selten boten ja sie haben
sich sehr erklärt oder effekte so
genommen die ganze theorie der grund der
karierten jetzt an wird das da
verschiedene vollständige gibt
tatsächlich habe die rückgänge die form
im katholischen bereich dass man jetzt
gar nicht mehr herum und sieht
kategorien schreibt sondern sein das
findet alles liebe gott statt
es geht dabei um die ganze theorie
pulver seit sich einfach für lieb und
für sehr fertig und denn am ende einer
zeit nicht unbedingt ein brechen der
sortie de ich meine dass sich der
biederen projektion in den sitz mit
ihren alkohol ist in der andere zieht
oder terrassentüren oder sophie gibt
sich ballack lange vor der inkarnation
möchte glichen ruft hilfe
es gibt zudem auf aussagen aus dem film
von stephen dewitt ja ist doch schön mit
denen sie bleibe das findet sie so
attraktiv habe baustelle von der
inkarnation sie das lied oh gott das
heim misere chance hat sich winters
entwickeln evolution klare vorstellung
für evolution und man könnte jetzt april
mutmaßt schmidt trug sie informationen
hat sich das sympathische gedanken
gefunden
als junge und hatten mehr über leitern
autorität die eintracht sagt das gibt es
ja unter wasser sagt das gibt es nicht
es gibt zwei möglichkeiten sie mit der
sache auseinandersetzen
es gibt wissenschaftliche landrat durch
das eine erst sehr viel später fahren
die sogenannte informations forschen
7-jährige holzen und es gibt möglichkeit
sozialprodukt so und also mal
ausprobieren und das ist bei mir so wie
gar nicht als sie den er ganz ins bild
gemacht als reinkarnation gesund
erklärte der mann zuerst therapie auge
sie ihren umstrittenen methode sehr
umstritten und verspricht ein reh oder
dass man seit es gibt weitere und wie
krieg wie trend wirklich schon alles
muss wird ein idealer form sie von der
reinkarnation das ist also das man
ebenfalls mit religiöse bezüge und
applaus - deswegen unplausibel kräften
auto.de farbigen mit den erschienen oder
auch das erlebe versterben verstorbene
erschienen spricht eigentlich dagegen
hatte er den der fahrer der hitze
grundmetall sowohl der bezüglich so also
die werden nie gegen sie wieder zurück
schickt also sondern sie sehen die man
eine andere wirklichkeit bereich also
zum dass anleger wo sie hängt also wurde
noch deutlicher entwicklung und uns rief
ich also um das buch zeigt sich die
ganze theorie von der reinkarnation
nicht aber was spricht dagegen dass
erneut nur vortrag schriebe wenn man
sechs milliarden und der seele bittet
gott und seid ihr mal auftauchte und
wurde diesmal anders machen und besser
und den zwei gute therapie heckseite
eskalation der durchschnitt der us- muss
glaubt andere inkarnation buddhismus die
ganz verschiedene fragen was meine
wäsche tradition theosophie und so
weiter aber die christliche theologie
das schau ich bin mainz gibt es etwa ein
gespräch aber solche leute hätten hier
sondern sowie quelle macht er wie zehn
informationsseminar spricht sowie das
man seit er vor über die nicht mache ich
weiß dass sie bucht eher verregnet mitte
als studentin wir voll im
materialistische waldwildnis 7,8 freunde
informiert der vater kam war bis vor
strom verstanden und ich als zwei
20-jährige grünschnabel hat ein vater
zeitlos sind aus theologie das ist groß
dass panik und wir kommen als 250 jahre
gemacht wie sicher ist ob er zu alt
erfahre seriös und zu beherzigen die
kinder horoskop gestellt etwas anders
angelegt
auch ich sagte das gibt's nicht willst
dass das gar nicht und ich habe es ja
fast haben und sagt warum ist ihre frau
das und zahl und jedes stück noch kurz
das geht auf remelé und sie macht habe
im bootshaus weg durch das meer ist um
eine million freeroll slave gott im
moment erlebt wir mit dem tod bestimmt
in einer islam nun zeit das ist ski und
board mitglied von 878 möchte
inhaltliche noch mal auf youtube einige
mühen anders und design wird für das
buch ich keine inflation keine
information scarabis ich habe mit dem
christlichen glauben vereinbar
dies gibt christliche theologie wo das
durchaus anders gesehen dass meine sich
gott
ganz klar wo eigentlich ein christlicher
glaube ganz wichtig ist eine
einmaligkeit vom leben aber da in
hollywood wurde person also für mich
immer wichtig dass das ja einmalig ist
und damit abgeschlossen ist wie wenn man
stehen kann ist entspricht jetzt gar
nicht mein wunsch den kapitel wieder
zurückzog also der singularität also die
einzigartigkeit von menschen aus meiner
sicht nicht nur sein dass man kann
versuchen anbieter auch die ganze die
menschheitsgeschichte also wenn sie
evolution ansprechen also ich finde
diese ganze lebenserfahrung sprechen
doch dafür dass es lieber eine einmalige
chance ist mir immer größer
menschheitsgeschichte innenstadt wo wo
mehr oder weniger ford seiten sich
entwickle so also die dfg zyklische
vorstellen können für mich in eine
andere wirklichkeit über zügelt wo
mindestens mit wieder hinter ganze
konzept sind oder sie schauen natürlich
zeigen dass es ganz verschiedene
integrations vorstelle gebiet aus ganz
verschiedenen traditionen dass die hat
bis zum teil oft noch während es im raum
vor der rechte der tradition der user
eigene reformations vorstände gilt also
als witz weil der kleine chance die wir
gern wieder steht damit in der mine die
größere macht sie gern zum schluss
einfach noch mal persönlich folge wie
die beschäftigung mit dem thema also
jetzt die zehn sitze probiert ein slogan
was hamburger über sage ihr habt dass
ihr das leben verändert vor maria das
ist das mist gemacht dass die
vereinfacher wählen und fahre und das
ist die bedingung ich sehe ja den
übrigen sagt astrologie und einfach mal
danke also es wird gewiss so dass leere
zwar gibt es das oder gibt es das in die
zone virtuose finde ist das relevant in
bezug auf die lage
erfolgs aus der erfahrung aus angst und
das ist unterirdisch reinkarnationen
ganze wichtigste maxi und die dank also
für meine größten auto und transall eine
perspektive
das ist für mich schon eine hilfe
priorität so was macht
wir wussten hier ist lustig sie dass sie
jede beschäftigung mit dem phänomen also
immer irgendwo blackwater bin also das
v6 thema ist wie fasziniert aber auch
heitere dem film also dass es auch
kreativ seite so etwas was die menschen
alles erleben das hätte durchaus als
tröstlich zu wissen dass menschen am
leben sind auch wenn sie immer bewusst
bewusst sie sind so positive intensive
erfahrung machen wie immer man das
erklärt wenn dir ganz toll tröstliche
perspektive erregend also das thema wo
ernst ich manchmal zwischen monster
herzlicher dank für das gespräch
danke letzte woche ich glaube meine
kollegin amira hafner al daradji autor
lorenz martins katholischen grenzgänger
wo erkenntnis aus der modernen
naturwissenschaften mit alte spirituelle
tradition verbindet und mit zeiget ein
film über sein vater der kurt marti wo
im februar gestorben ist jetzt gott sei
wieder in der sternstunde musik mit dem
wunderbaren film über tellja fitzgerald
phänomenal sängerin wird einfach über
man ihren hund stadtgeburtstag krone 4
[Musik]